[Music]
imagine if we could go back in time
imagine if we could see what our ocean
looked like in a world with less human
impact marine protected areas offer us a
glimpse of this dream only five thousand
in number
they are the nature reserves at the
scene
[Music]
countries have agreed that 10% of marine
and coastal areas must be protected by
2020 but today only one in ten countries
protect more than 2% of their marine
areas
[Music]
marine protected areas like nature
reserves on land nurture recovery and
bring new economic opportunities yet
most existing marine parks and reserves
are vastly underfunded
without effective stewardship
surveillance and accountability marine
protected areas have failed to provide
the safe sanctuaries they promise to
deliver the risks run higher in
developing countries and traditional
coastal communities or inhabitants stand
to lose the marine resources they depend
on
[Music]
how can we together ensure that 10% of
our ocean will be efficiently protected
by 2020
[Music]